[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOY PAYTON: If you
want to learn how
to be a data scientist because
you think this is interesting,
then you definitely need to
be involved with Google Cloud
platform, because one of
the best ways to learn data
is using big data.
And there is a great
set of resources for you
in Google Public data
sets in BigQuery, which is
a great place to get started.
There's tons of tutorials
that'll help you there
that are available at no cost.
The hosting of data
sets is at no cost.
And all the work that you need
to do can be done in free tier.
So there are lots of ways that,
even without participating
in a formal training process
or signing up for an exam,
that you can grow your
skills and really find a data
set that you're
passionate about.
I tell people if you love
sports, look at sports data.
If you're concerned
about hunger and poverty,
look for those data sets.
Find something you care about.
And you will definitely
find some trends that
make you scratch your
head, or make you angry,
or make you excited, or
make you ask questions.
So find some data, work with
it, and change the world.